he doing anything but you still gotta
wake up at four o'clock in the morning
for five o'clock in the morning yeah
yeah well he doesn't get up that all
right anymore
much do you guys think that submission
costs
so so I always hear that girls say they
need the Right leader to be feminine and
submit to a guy like they can't just be
feminine and send it to anyone so at
what income do you need a guy to make to
submit to him and Trust his judgment
and what do you and like the reverse of
this guy's point of view do you think
there should be a minimum that girls
should
money-wise yeah yeah
this is a question Kevin Samuels always
would ask you see the thing is
um yeah the thing it depends in in where
I'm at so
am I earning more than you if I'm
earning more than you if I if you're on
18 000 a year and I'm not 22 then I'm
the guy
you know it I I don't think there's I
believe that it's it's in you or it's
not I might have a masculine or I'm not
you're either feminine or you're not and
if you are feminine the masculine guys
will find you and they will want you
and if you're so I don't know I don't
think it's a money thing I think it's
because for me you could be a CEO and
earn 250 and I could earn 50. like
you're not batting me up like that I'm
still gonna back you up I'm still King
of the castle like and
I've I've seen that play out um it's
just you are who you are I can't become
submissive because you make more money
than me I'm not gonna do it it's just
not it's just not in my DNA so I I don't
know I don't
I don't think money I can't con quantify
it so so devil's advocate here right if
I'm thinking I'm gonna trust the
leadership of a guy that I'm dating
right and where I'm trusting him to make
the decisions and obviously I have to
vet the guy yeah and so when they say
that submission costs I think a lot of
times like it's misconstrued where what
women need mean is we need a competent
leader right and it's not the bomb right
so at some point at some point there
it's hard to quantify because we can all
think of someone that maybe doesn't make
a lot of money but is very competent but
in general like there is a point where
there is a point yeah there is a point
but um
from a female's perspective I'd be
looking for like is he solid he's solid
he does his own thing you don't ask
nobody for nothing and he just keeps it
moving he's self-sufficient he's
self-sufficient and you know I've always
been self-sufficient so I don't need
nothing from you so you wanna give me
something he's holding a steady job
at the very least yeah and yeah yeah and
he doesn't have any debt and he doesn't
have any debt and he's not making stupid
decisions yeah yeah okay what about you
and do you actually question for my guys
do you think if a girl makes a lot of
money and she's very competent that she
should be able to submit to the average
guy even if she's more competent than
him
I
I don't know okay the thing is I don't
think they will but I think it depends
on the guy like if if we meet up and
that's your that's how you do I'm we're
just gonna bump heads until one submits
and it ain't gonna be me so if it's
gonna be you then we can work and
sometimes it does take that for I'm not
gonna say all the time sometimes it does
take an alpha male to just like make an
alpha female know her place sometimes
but you know it's either in you or it's
not okay what do you think
um how much it would take to to submit
to a guy
um kind of backing off on what he was
saying
um it'd have to just depend on how you
are like you can be making millions of
pounds and whatnot and not be smart with
your money I'm saying
um
but then again you can have
that much money to an it to a point
where even if you are stupid with your
money it's not really gonna go anywhere
that's what I'm saying so
um I'd say
for me to be submissive
number one I'll have to respect you
first and foremost and respect like your
decisions and everything like that
um
I don't know I I wouldn't say I'd put a
price on it
okay but respect I I'm not gonna lie and
say I wouldn't respect someone that's
making more than me to an extent like if
you're making more than me have some
sort of respect for you but yeah you
could be making more with me and I've
not be right with your money but I'd
have to respect you first and foremost
but I'd say
yeah I don't know I've there's not
really a prize
would you so it's like roughly just
being able to take care of himself have
his own place have like that sort of
thing yeah would you submit two guy that
lives at his mom's house
hmm
in the rent
yeah
um let's let's say no okay
no okay what about you
a fat laptop is it permanent
um no I'm saying what income so the
first question is what income
I I agree with her in terms of I
wouldn't put a price on it okay and I
feel like
like I said relationship is compromised
sorry
[Music]
relationship is compromised and yeah to
compromise there's a bit of submission
required on both parts that's what I
would say
oh actually in the the mom's house does
he have to be paying rent at the mom's
house for you to submit
let's say he's been living there for two
years
I think I would still submit back again
depends on the situation like is he
saving money to buy a house versus is he
just living there to live there yeah
yeah
and it depends on my own situation as
well
yeah
okay what about you I've never dated
anyone that's earned more than me
okay and I've always been submissive no
problem okay but it's Gotta Be
responsible it'll be a man yeah yeah
it's got to be a man do you agree I
think a lot of guys can if a even if a
guy makes less money if he's overly
masculine like I think he can get
like I think masculinity gives guys a
lot of points especially in like today's
day and age where the men I think
struggle with masculinity more than ever
yeah my mind's hot
he's very masculine I actually got um
we've got custom
I think something Sarah said once and I
said that I was on holiday and I had on
the shorts shorts like short shorts and
a little top and I was at home and
somebody made a comment a man made a
comment towards the way I looked so I
haven't mentioned it to my man who was
in England at the time and he said what
were you wearing he saw us he goes but
there's men around the house you're too
old to be wearing stuff like that so I
said right then I changed and I got rid
of it all and I was told that
I was whipped and I was like my man's
telling me that I'm dressing
appropriately so I've changed my clothes
but what I supposed to listen to a woman
but they seem to think that because I
was earning more than him
but he's the head of relationships I
Don't Need No Man girl that's what they
think
girl when they're in bed on their own at
night they tell me I don't need a man